you
hi everyone it's Jerry I am on leeches
org and I'm gonna play a 15-10 game
let's try you for first time playing
against this player okay
games are in this standard playlist that
I have with E 4 E 5 alright
I'd have three days okay so decision
time ray Lopez or scotch
hmm
what
to do well let's try for Ray Lopez 86
Knight f6 Knight f6 okay I think I'm
just going to play it solid and d3 and
we're in for something strategic
I mean and he just paused for a moment
yeah okay let's go with D three all
right I think it's important at this
point to not allow Knight d4 so the
reason I say this is cuz you know if I
Castle Knight d4 we exchange Knights my
bishop kind of feels a bit stranded and
black can gain some valuable Tempe the
one that really comes to mind for me is
c6 multi-purpose strikes at the bishop
and supports a d5 advance so same story
in the center with our pawns
hmm well this night is now pinned
if I play d4 black has to take otherwise
d5 is gonna pick up material d4 takes
takes if the bishop backs up d5 after
this takes takes Bishop b4 is necessary
d4 takes takes bishop beef on Bishop b4
Bishop d2 threatening the bishop
Bishop takes Bishop Knight takes I like
that I have some speedy development and
a nice Center and still potential to
maybe take out the night and play
against the doubled pawns I want to give
this a go if black doesn't
it's kind of backing up idea because it
interferes with this you know sometimes
when you're in this this pin your way
out is to play a six and after the
Bishop backs up b5 but a bishop on b6
does not allow for the b5 advance to
break the pin so pretty interesting
starts your six moves in took a couple
steps with d4 but uh yeah I'm trying to
highlight this this pin that is present
this seemed a little bit off no no let's
just uh carry on with it so this is
mandatory I think okay and yeah Bishop
d2 it is so
that um I'm going to have a a nice
Center okay I'm pretty sure I just
recapture with this guy need to defend
e4 so both my Knights control these
points efore is the more accessible one
anticipating a rook here and I
we want to be in a position to meet rook
e8 with rook e1 leaning towards castles
right now one other thought that's
crossing my mind is to maybe take a step
to prevent the pin this may actually be
something h3 or castles h3 rook here I
can't I can't really get away with this
move in fact black and maybe just take
on this square okay I'm just gonna end
up allowing the pin if it happens and
yeah I think actually if the bishop is
committed in this and this side of the
board all certainly think about damaging
the Queen side and then playing against
the CC pawns as I was pointing out
earlier with this d4 advance so decision
his black hair about having a CC pun
we'll see
get challenged Bishop g4 with threatened
Knight takes so Bishop g4 I'll probably
knock the night out recapture and then
maybe rook e1 or ask the bishop a
question I'm not sure Bishop g4 yeah I
have to pretty much take the knight out
it's too difficult to defend oh well
that's interesting yeah pretty pretty
cool maneuver Black is going with ff4 is
sensitive and I don't have a convenient
way to defend f4 with a piece so and I
cannot allow a knight to just sit there
so what does this mean I need to be
prepared to play g3 I'm going to have
some weaknesses and I want my bishop
around to help repair those weaknesses
also I
be prepared to meet a6 or c6 with Bishop
back therefore this is the correct move
pretty sure I want to get here in 1 and
1 go just tuck them back this is an
enormous piece this is worth a it's a
5.9 on f4 f5 squares ok so here we are I
do not necessarily have to go to f1
may not I may not go to f1 d3 is the
other move I'm considering Bishop d3 for
what though this night is going to go
here in fact what does this Knight do
its next best move is to go to this
square so even if my bishop is on this
diagonal ya know it's also on an
unprotected square let's let's let's opt
for some security just tuck my bishop
away everything is defended except for
this guy the big difference here is with
regard to the structure
pandu o vs this guy now how exactly to
challenge c5 I could play this d5 I can
play that if this move is played that
would certainly weaken blacks Kings side
with three minor pieces still around
Queens on board well all pieces besides
the dark square Bishop I would not mind
seeing that move so I imagine it's a
comfortable for black also at any point
I could question this night's post
though I would give up a good square on
d5 for now I just like keeping the pawns
sitting and slowly build up Queen c2
comes to mind
watches b2 b4 maybe at some point takes
away a natural well a likely flight
square h6
are the h7 square
Bishop g4 9 g6 rookie 896 it is I think
I want to go right in for it g3 I mean I
could play Queen c2 and as soon as the
knight arrives on f4 give it a boo
but I don't even like the idea of the
night possibly jumping into h3 I'm just
going to rule it out just trying to
control the night
quickly resolved with age three if it
backs up black has to be concerned about
being trapped don't know that I would
want to do that move I don't want to
make that move because I'm giving up a
wonderful square piece Sakura I'm really
asking for some peace sacrifice Bishop
here h3 bishop back I don't think I'll
be pine g4g for Knight takes pawn takes
Bishop takes I have to worry about 9 f4
after worry about have 5 I'm still have
to sort out a pin
it's probably an incorrect sacrifice but
can certainly be tricky to defend one of
those objectively bad but might have
some practical possibilities rook e8
seems pretty sensible so if this move in
h3
does back up I think I'll maybe deploy
my queen
all influence
like that move hmm where do I want to go
with my Queen Queen see - I'm thinking
also maybe B for its kind of get on with
a minority attack maybe I shouldn't I
shouldn't rush with something like that
I mean I was I was thinking you know
maybe Queen B 3 but it feels a little
bit uncomfortable to Block in the pond I
mean what is my way forward if I can
make three moves in a row what am i what
am i doing you know aside from this
Clinton this kind of stuff
[Music]
well I'm I'm really just drawn towards
Queen c2 about I mean I I can look to
break in the center to try to prep that
okay and this this seems just interests
seems like a good move I'm connecting
rooks I'm watching over an important
square it's clearly some it's a focal
point I could think about anchoring a
knight on d6 so this rook move there's a
nice little prize I get if my knight
does arrive on d6 this could be this
could be a plan for sure in fact I am
I'm kind of liking this idea so let's
just
dummy move is played I mean this has its
purpose H sex flight square so on h6
would I really play e5 e five takes
takes night here I have night to one of
these two and then I get into D six each
six here takes takes 97 night c4 I'm car
I'm guarding this in 96 is something
we'll see oh okay well here we go each
six black has that flight square in it
now I think I think it's really time to
do this I'm a tiny bit of head
development wise black has snuck in the
flight square but his two moves behind
development wise so it's time to time to
calculate some or just put the move on
e5 just seems like the way to go I wanna
kind of anticipate a little bit as
things open up some do I have
coordination I do Knights are connected
rooks are connected Bishop is snug where
is black vulnerable at the moment the
rook is unprotected but I don't see that
being too much of an issue let's say e5
takes takes 95 Knights c4 if I go Knight
e4 and I'm in a pin here takes takes
Knight d5 so these
you're just off the board I have a pawn
on e5 just try my best to visualize that
position wipe on here and that's the
only center pun am I sure the night is
gonna go to d5 you know if he goes
backwards then okay Knight c4 in that
position after Knight d5 Knight f4
that's not combined with anything else I
wanna go in for this ne5 it is so I'm
giving up
Square d5 but in general and this this
should be the right approach being ahead
and development wise and I'm getting a
square as well definitely recapturing
with this piece I do not want to
exchange these guys f3 is better than g6
also I could see this as now I have
space so let's keep some minor pieces on
at some point this may be a possibility
to undermine the knight on g6 black wolf
pretty good squares with the pieces but
I have space pawn on e5 that pawn on e5
so black is really considering maybe
going here or maybe Knight h7
hmm
too much in a hurry to play e5 Knight d5
Knight c4 Bishop g4 strikes an
unprotected night if I move them I'm
losing five mmm I may have to prep a
little bit more before I could play
Knight c4 in to d6 maybe there isn't a
rush
thinking 95 Bishop g2 but there is night
here oh man oh yeah ok I didn't consider
that but now I don't have to worry about
Bishop Bishop g4 huh what is the idea
here
clearly e5 is under fire push there's
takes takes the rook takes all right
well the first move I'm thinking about
is Knight c4 and there's a nice tempo to
gain against the Queen this really feels
like a game that could end soon black
isn't careful and I think I don't know
I'm ahead in development and I feel that
I could be winning some more time let's
say maybe even winning some material so
for example of h3 is and where's the
knight go if this isn't to move h3 right
now Knight takes Knight takes Knight
takes ok
thinking about nine c4 and night c4
Queen here hits where I'm a little bit
vulnerable but I do have Bishop g2 and
that Queens position cannot be
maintained much longer I believe the way
forward is to start with nine c4 so II
five is a big focal point now rook d1
right around the corner Knight d6 h3
possibilities it could be its
I lost four black well see there may be
some annoying pin in fact Queen here man
well it puts pressure on this pawn it
prepares to meet h3 with a capture but
Queen c7 h3 Knight takes Knight takes
let's check this again Queen c7 h3
Knight takes Knight takes Knight takes
f4 that's why I want to take with this
Knight the rook is unprotected when the
Queen goes to c7 highlighting the one
well
highlighting the fact that the rook is
unprotected no no no no no no no no no
hang on for a second here
let's not blunder Queen c7 h3 Knight
takes Knight takes Knight takes f4 is
met with Knight f3 and a black and gets
the last laugh
so Queen c7 I can consider this
something black
maybe able to ignore Queen c7 here maybe
there's just this and they takes work
night takes night and I'm in a fork
Queen c7 I could consider this move it
seems purposeful defends the palm okay
scratch that so a Bishop g2 is what I
was pointing out this Queen can't stay
here for much longer
pressure on my
Bishop g2 is my first thought
anything else going on here any
spectacular moves no oh
there might be something spectacular
Bishop f5 Queen takes Queen takes Knight
huh
I don't have to
bishop let's put on Bishop g2
hmm well what's the story here my Queens
unprotected b5 is threat my first
thought is b4 just to make sure my night
isn't going to go into any I have any
problems
well I think before maybe the winning
move so one two three four one two three
for Queen takes pawn and then h3
B for Queen takes pawn h3 and I takes F
to clean takes I dropped the night I
takes F to King takes b4 takes h3 Knight
takes and winning a piece just concerned
about my king shelter so be for Queen
takes h3 I don't see what I'm missing so
let's get in B form there is also that
if I just made a passive move like an
RFP one night takes after to is an idea
can't take with the Queen in that case
all right excuse me can't take with the
king in that case I'd have to take with
the Queen
take with the Queen and then I would
drop tonight so what does black do
eventually I could think I think I'm
just winning some material here so black
may be able to get a couple pawns maybe
with this variation my king should be
quite all right though oh I'm even
seeing a fancy move Queen takes bh3
Knight takes f2 King takes f2 Queen c5
check preparing to play this move but um
you know I could always get out of that
b5 move with the 93 and even on a queen
c5 check with if I could play Knight e3
block then you block that check and
defend my queen
so let's go in for it here we are I
think one of these two has to be knocked
out so I believe I'm soon gonna be up
just a tiny bit material-wise and still
little bit development wise this guy
still needs to move maybe ignore
Bishop e6 I could jump in hmm that's
what they're doing
okay 96
ninety six and nine takes pawn queen as
sure there yeah I don't I don't like
that
96 Knight takes pawn Knight takes Knight
takes Knight two pawns in a yeah No
maybe I need to just go here
anymore night back to d2
hmm
96 night yeah and they take spot I don't
like that I think I have to go back up
not another terrible move to have to
make I don't think because I am I am
just coordinating some
I think blacks should be taking one of
these too this is the one that scares me
the most because it exposes my King some
here here Queen b6 I wasn't voicing it
but I could be and hmm I think I could
afford to put myself into a pin and then
get out of it with rook b1 because these
other squares are covered
it's my night I could shoo the Queen off
of this diagonal and then maybe even
double up
I'll see but this is the one that
concerns me most this one here I
maintain a very nice shelter for my king
take a center pond but I don't have any
King worries
so let's see what black does I'm pretty
sure you have to take one of these too
right now I wouldn't mind taking like
this this night remains out of play
hey and now we finally Bank some
material any bishop move I could take a
rook with Chuck pretty much even on the
clock
so two pawns a knight versus two pawns
position what I like to have happen here
my okay with a queen trade probably
Knight is under fire
oh I think
full square I was thinking here but I
like I like f1 actually get to that f5
square
yeah this this seems well
hanging but I could connect them seems
like the right thing to do anything else
to consider I don't think there's too
much
let's go night f1 this is very cozy over
here everything is defended except these
two but they're they're ready to be
defended rook here I could consider some
kind of sacrifices possibly once my
miners maybe approach the king or
or maybe maybe I try to win upon I don't
want to lose this pawn three connected
passers that's that's too much Knight f3
I thought Bishop here would be played if
this pawn is converted into a deep on
I'll definitely lean towards exchanging
Queens especially now with a clock
situation trading Queens
maybe not objectively best but I'm able
to play a little bit faster in the
endgame that is many tricks when the
Queens aren't around okay and here we
are both rooks under fire and out
doubling up seems nice
I'm going to consolidate a little bit
more doubling up how do I get rid of
that Bishop
I know the computer would probably point
this out it's their way to tack this
pawn just double up and then undermine
that Bishop how do I do that yeah I'm
going to double up I'll see this bishop
kind of freezes this these two guys this
one can advance maybe okay offering a
queen exchange I think I want to keep
the ladies on actually just sneak in a
fast move with a punch keep this guy
defended
[Music]
maybe here and then here I don't have
that night to worry about anymore
my g4 is a good move
g4 I don't want to make use of this
squares pointing out earlier but yeah I
don't like that it inner it interferes
with my coordination I'll keep
everything glued together try to be
harmonious as I move forward and try and
steadily improve now rook advance I'm
not saying that would that be great move
but as soon as this rook steps up he's
unprotected so these okay so the rook is
they're defending the same time
something that I could get in like that
um let's get in a fast minute let's
let's go here for a moment
expecting bloc to offer a queen exchange
Oh
pick up upon okay just get that pond out
of harm's way
what can't move still I would fall I
haven't given up on this okay there here
we go
so things are heating up let's get my
night playing to watch for the back
ranks my opponents back rank is more
vulnerable than mine didn't consider
that these guys are now split I think I
just have to take have my back rank
covered okay
and centralized with the punch
oh I was thinking there's a rook move
here now there isn't so this is right
around the corner I think this is just
God now knight on f5 clean takes and
then the mates these guys are so far off
from posing any serious threat um okay
offering Queen exchange yes I want to
keep the Queen's on
I
filling with my time ticking down I'm
going to exchange Queens and target this
guy mm-hmm well I
change I should exchange and now let's
go here for starters I wouldn't mind
seeing us repeat for a moment I think in
the end I'll block or I even have this
move possibly yeah that that should that
should work this pawns falling
alright let's put this on defense and
attack I can't get stuff
it's got its coming together now rook
takes pawn bishop here I have a check
check
take possibly okay
this first kind of just alleviate the
pressure against this pawn hmm so now I
think we're ready to take
Bishop here I have the check and then a
check and then take here and have to
worry about f2 or I could check okay so
they're sidestepping that
secure square I'm going after this palm
next it's no way to get at my king when
he's on g2
[Music]
let's uh that's it
I want to go here and then give a check
are you
then go here I'm going after the king
let's start with this check the King
goes back I have
I want to I want to get rid of this
Bishop I could go here Bishop takes pawn
I could take take check and then take
here all right be a little bit careful
mm-hmm so let's take demote the king
[Music]
Bishop f3 I have the H 1 square covered
close to me
quite I could even move my name in fact
night here's forcing bishop takes
or
yeah I'll go in for this it's nice
Donna light-square threatening mate now
back rank King can't run row can't do
anything to defend
there's no wrong color
situation either I didn't look into that
until this point
behind is where it belongs pawn push I
could take straightaway or insert the
check mm-hmm I think I don't even want
to allow that pond to get to this square
so let's just put the bishop here rook
here bishop here or yeah to a square so
that I'm threatening to take here and
defend my bishop could this count and
this pawn caused me a problem that's
where I'm gonna shoot for but actually I
think I see a clear a clear approach now
involves getting this guy rolling
supercooling my bishop in keeping my
rope cutting the King off also I could
think
this just as my night was helping
control you know I get my pawn to this
square
kingi - here here it's getting pretty
serious start with this first now I'm
threatening to win the pawn I think this
is a good technique I approach so far
the rook has two responsibilities stop
this and defend this so my King asks the
brook a question and now he has to
choose one mm-hmm oh that even oh right
that defends I could still ask a
question though here the
there's no defense like here here okay
so I could I could take the pawn now
like if I've had time I just stepped my
King up once actually
I could even allow the Queen to be on
the board if my King is here I'll be
getting a mate I I'm I was just very III
don't want to do my my rook I want to
I'm kind of playing for mate now let's
see how fast these pawns can run
okay I'm just gonna take him now
he's scaring me okay well let's step up
and okay let's let's just gather the
pawn these guys cannot be challenged
actually let me just establish a king
position first this is a nice square
king takes bishop take advantage of the
pin illegal okay keep the king position
prepared to me to a check with the block
if I had over if it was only an H pawn
would be a different story
what's the cleanest approach here
I'm gonna step up with my king no fancy
stalemates here for black don't have to
worry about that mm-hmm okay so I could
do this I'm prepared
to transfer my truck to a difference
Square and covering this right now King
moves this pawn bolts
[Music]
oh well I could get the
and now the rook isn't there King here
rook somewhere okay I think I just want
to insert a check first about this
actually get out of the rooks view here
then
no actually I'm blocking okay let's not
block the cleanest approach and there's
no steel maze that King has this square
let's just go here got g2 defended this
is next the rook has to go back we just
exchanged rooks no stalemates no steel
mates
all right
and me okay all right this was an
interesting one I wasn't expecting it to
really open up so much in this opening
is expecting a bit more of a strategic a
slower a slower approach okay let's see
what the analysis is saying I'll
computer somebody already clicked on
that so I
nice Center that's really where it
started for me this may be an issue no
not quite
d6 but I am getting a nice Pandu oh and
if if black doesn't react well enough
then alright if black is not timely
let's say then it really it really is an
asset I wonder if maybe castles is
called for here I mean the concern
certainly is that if castles I could
maybe take and then take actually I
think maybe this would be played this
might be a move I don't know I'm a
little bit behind development wise I
don't know if I would really want to
even take that bomb if you get it pretty
crazy I wonder if the computer would be
suggesting d6 or castles here
hmm felt comfortable so maybe there's a
more some black has to pull off some
more more accurate move right around
this point because this is just a
lasting advantage
no I took the steps to neutral
I know for and by this point you know
hum up a tiny bit timewise and I think
once a five is in I don't know it's
really gonna go I don't know if I let an
advantage slip let's have a look at the
analysis inaccuracies mistakes and
blunders for each what is it saying let
me just flick it on here what is it
saying about this move d600 wants to
play d5 how about that d5 or castles um
okay so what's this defy first let's
just see this move so I was already
putting these moves on so suppose I go
try to win upon it wants to take with
the beep on and then if I take here d5
yeah pretty sharp and if I take here now
Queen e8 Queen d6 yeah yeah yeah Queen
e8 you know this is a problem I mean
black is Castle didn't look at how
quickly things turn this is better for
black
so this is important to note I think
I've had this same position I don't know
in a slower game but I'm pretty sure
I've had a I've played as black in this
position and this was certainly a
concern for me the the idea to you know
if I castled chop-chop
but you know there are these resources
when you take with the beep on and then
you try to put this guy straight to work
start breaking down the light squares
and black is doing to white what I was
trying to do too and in this game take
advantage of you know put put to use
this lead in development black has that
okay let's stop flipping so d5 is also
another one d5 and
I guess with similar ideas I mean if I'm
trying to pick up material castles and
yeah I'm really behind development wise
and I don't have a great square in fact
it's gonna take three moves before these
guys could feel you know satisfied with
the square there on this is just a pivot
point and that's gonna want to go
somewhere else from d2 okay after d6 I
do get in d4 and establish this nice
Center once more this could be met with
d5 a6 there isn't a b5 move I guess
there is Bishop a5 but even so black is
just barely hanging on here it's lucky
to just kind of get out of this without
losing material and even if I don't win
material in this position this is still
desirable structure development is cool
and we go from there it was like b5 have
to be played that's really weakening I
mean you could that's a half dead pawn
okay in short you can't go to b6 Bishop
b4 in the game wants just Castle here
that's interesting
who is this where no okay once with
castles castles preparing to meet this
with takes first
okay once we're in this middle game
position as I like that idea it likes
that idea that night reposition that
really I don't know surprise me during
the game I think it's a good maneuver so
we're good
where is there an improvement Bishop d3
Bishop f1 I guess it's a coin flip I
wanted some security a5 a5 Bishop e6 are
called for um b4 I was thinking about b4
here b4 b4 Queen b3 a for I wouldn't
want to go a 4 coz of this and then I
don't know I'm kind of afraid of not a
queen so much on b4 but if somehow
Knight gets there I would rather go with
b4 first and then a 4 I wouldn't want to
allow this pawn to clamp down on this
structure ok b4 I did not go for its
control Queen c2 and I guess this isn't
best be 5 is I'm in a rush I guess
I shouldn't be going with e5 so I guess
black is just going to miss one key move
somewhere in the middle game and then
it's kind of it's kind of gone once it's
h3 Bishop e3 this point where the knight
is trapped once there's a material
advantage I guess I did all right with
not allowing any counter play so what is
suggested here Bishop d3 so just a
little bit more prep work what's a train
of thought I could use to maybe hold
myself back from playing e5 in future
games maybe I can say to myself black
can't prevent me from playing e5 so
let's get a little bit more prep working
and we'll do one move later put the
Bishop on a better position yeah okay so
after this h6 move Bishop here right
right right and then with e5 I'm
threatening a knight ready to smash
through on g6
so Bishop d3 Knight FA King G - oh I
couldn't maybe see myself playing King
to g2 here
stop Bishop h3 actually come to think of
it Bishop d3 isn't this may be a bother
mm-hmm
computer would be cool with just you
know grabbing a pond like that giving up
the LightSquared Bishop dealing with
this this Bishop but I don't know that's
that's kind of scary
but anyhow that I could maybe prep it a
little bit more even if I don't go in
for this Bishop d3 move maybe maybe I
could go forward with a b4 move an a4
move and b5 move there's nothing
stopping me from playing e5 so I I have
control over when this move should be
played I mean I do thing is I am giving
up a nice square to the night end and
even the bishop okay so maybe some prep
work this caught me off guard Knight g4
I guess it's no it's not quite losing
but I guess after I play here after the
Queen move it's gone I guess this is
where it's kind of gone Queen d5 yeah so
black has to
accurate here and play a Bishop e6 move
ooh
Bishop e6 or b5 hmm
let's have a look at this one Bishop e6
probably jump in here but yeah there's
this idea to take on this square cuz in
the end there's this four it's not
working this is what this is better for
black maybe a winning four block in a
computer versus computer game
I mean minus one point one is serious oh
well I'd have to come up with Bishop d3
here the Bishop takes Knight Bishop
takes g6 oh no not that that would lose
the the house Bishop d5 and Bishop b4
and the game continues yeah
black needed to be timely here because
of this this threat once I had this
secured there's no
for this because I could take with this
night and the Queen's under fire
so she's just not a reliable defender is
the thing this guy needed to be
challenged hmm easy to go wrong easy to
not find the correct continuation here
but that's that's really what it's
coming down to just one one wrong move
here and in the end I'm getting in the
h3 and material is in my pocket and b4
is good and then aged 396 well I thought
I couldn't play 96 because of because of
what Oh in this
session 96 wasn't a good move because of
night for takes Knight takes rook
tonight takes f3 and I'm not even up
material yeah opponent has a night and
two pawns for the rook so I need to go
to secure square Knight c2 d2 and then
the computer wants to take out f2 so
yeah this is the one that concerned me
most the one that's going to expose my
king and what's still with the Queen's
on may be there could be some pressure
against me I takes F - King takes F -
Queen b6 I was gonna play rook e3 and
then look to shoe the Queen away any
five rook be one Queen a7 and I could
try to get out of the pin like this okay
I'm um I'm still cozy here and here's
the other thing the night I'm up a
little bit of material and also the
night is just not contributing because
of this guy and once that was in and I
guess it's just gonzo from there a
growing a growing graph yeah I think I
would I would want to keep the Queen's
on but the time situation said just
trade Queens and go for something simple
and uh yeah just went after the King
some I think the conversion was clean
enough
okay well as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this game in the comment
section below
hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye
you